[Applause]
he defied expectations but there's no
rest for this Prime Minister determined
to turn a shock result into the new
state of clove bars Johnson knows that
his victory rally in the seat of one of
Labour's most successful leaders must be
more than a fluke he wants a piece of
Tony Blair's appeal to hold these seats
he has a plan to act fast back up his
promises with cold hard cash and win the
trust of northern voters with
infrastructure spending and NHS money
written into law but if there's pressure
on Boris Johnson there's a heavier
burden on Jeremy Corbyn the party is now
soul-searching I started a period of
bowling we need to be able to have a
chance to stop and think and the old
guard are crumbling away both John
McDonnell and mr. Corbin will be gone in
months but what comes next there's a
whole range of youngsters that have come
through who I call them youngsters but
actually they're really well experienced
there's a new generation coming through
Rebecca long Bailey Angela Rana Richard
burger this whole group of them and you
can see a foot you can see a coalition
forming that can give us
I think the future that this country
needs and many have written into Sunday
newspapers today explaining what went
wrong the leader himself has also
written an article accepting
responsibility while still claiming his
policies and their direction he took the
partying was right many disagree but who
will take his place and will the
direction they choose be enough to
rebuild the red wall the Conservatives
have taken down Kate McCann's going news